there is a blockbuster story being
reported with explosive claims this is a
developing story there is a former NSA
analyst claiming that Donald Trump is
targeting American journalists with help
from Russian intelligence and referring
to John Schindler who's a security
expert former counterintelligence
officer he tweeted very recently and we
have the tweet for you learned from a
very reliable IC sources intelligence
community sources that Trump White House
with help from Russian intelligence is
targeting American journalists rough
road ahead
get ready peeps it's not clear yet in
what way the journalists are being
targeted how credible is John Schindler
well well we do have every indication
that politically he's a conservative as
he says no reason to doubt that he was
one of the people reporting on the
Hillary Clinton email scandal pretty
early on he was one of the first people
to call out Julian Assange as being
involved with Russian intelligence we
should naturally be skeptical of all
claims that are made but John Schindler
has done some good reporting he was
mostly followed by conservatives during
his earlier reporting when it was about
the Hillary email scandal up until he
got into the Trump Russia stuff and all
of a sudden conservatives want nothing
to do with this guy but his credentials
check out he's been tuned into more or
less every national security scandal
that has come up recently he could have
ulterior motives that aren't clear yet
and his detractors Pat are already only
talking about he had this sort of minor
scandal he was involved in where you
know he sent a woman pictures of his
penis which doesn't exactly communicate
the best judgment for a former
intelligence officer but that being said
you know we still have to analyze the
claims for what they are evidence has
not yet been given to support the claims
but historically
someone that generally has been on top
of national security stories yeah I mean
just because he's conservative though
that doesn't mean necessarily he's a
trump supporter so I have every reason
to be skeptical here I also find it kind
of hard to believe that the Trump
administration would continue working
with Russian officials after all these
hacks and leaks came out
you think that they would have the mind
to stop doing that but maybe you're just
that brazen or that stupid I guess we
know that they're brazen and there's a
lot of evidence to suggest that they're
stupid but you would think even the
dumbest most brazen people would say hey
you know what every day there's breaking
news about our connection to Russia
maybe we'll stop working with Russia for
now if indeed we are that's a fair point
I don't know exactly what those
conversations are like but yeah the
Russian news is not good over the last
week including of course that Trump
Attorney General Jeff Sessions met twice
with the Russian ambassador to the US
last year was deceptive about the
meetings we just a few weeks ago had
National Security Advisor Michael Flynn
resign in total shame after having lied
about the subject matter that he
discussed with the Russian ambassador
which did include sanctions US sanctions
on Russia and a new poll found that a
majority of Americans would support a
congressional investigation into the
claims that the Trump administration has
close ties with Russia and did during
the presidential campaign so all not
good we will follow the allegations from
John Schindler see if we have evidence
supporting them but explosive claims and
we will see what happens I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman follow me there